ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครับผมวันนี้เรามาเจอ
กับเพียบน้องเรียนอีกแล้วนะครับในช่องคอม
friend สโมทัยครับวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวัน
อะไรครับวันนี้
วันนี้วันพุธค่ะอ้าววันนี้วันพุธโอเคครับ
วันพุธที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้
วันพุธที่สามสิบห้าวันพุธที่สามสิบกว่า
แค่เดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนมีนาคม 5 เดือนมีนาคมปีพศ.อะไรครับ
ทีนี้
ข้อ
2020  2555 ใจแล้ว 2022 แล้วปีพศ.อะไร
ครับ
พ.ศ 2 คัน
565 โอเค
2565 นะครับแล้ว 5 ตอนนี้เราคุยที่เรามา
ถ้าเจอกันตอนนี้ครับกี่โมงครับตอนนี้
ตอนนี้
เที่ยง 15  5 เที่ยง 15 นาทีโอเคอ่า
เที่ยง 15 นาทีหิวข้าวหรือยังครับ
หิวหรือยังอยู่แล้วแล้วกินหรือยังครับกิน
ข้าวหรือยังกินข้าวเที่ยงยังไม่ได้กิน
ด้วยโอเคอะเฮียตีก็ยังไม่ได้กินข้าว
เที่ยงเหมือนกัน
แต่พี่อติกินข้าวเช้าแล้วกินข้าวเช้าแล้ว
โอเค
ตีก็มีเรื่องอะไรมันเล่าเล่าให้ออกวันนี้
ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้มีเรื่อง
ๆโอเควันนี้มีหนังอีกเรื่องนึงอ่ะพี่
เตรียมหนักนี้เรื่องหนึ่งที่จะมาเล่าให้
นักเรียนฟังเรื่องนี้ครับนี้น้องยังเคยดู
หนังเรื่องนี้ไหมนั่งเล่นนี้เลยค่ะภาษาผม
ชื่อเมนอินแบล็คห้าใช่ครับภาษาไทยภาษาไทย
เพียบที่จำไม่ได้ชื่อจราชนอะไรสักอย่าง
หนึ่งแล้ว
แต่คนไทยคนไทยถ้าถ้าบอกว่า mib คนไทยก็จะ
อ๋ออ๋อเรื่องนี้ mib อ้าใช่ครับคนไทยก็จะ
รู้จักในเรื่องนี้จะมีผู้ชายอยู่ 2 คนผู้
ชาย 2 คนนี้เป็นตำรวจ
อ่ะแพ้ไม่ใช่ตำรวจที่ที่จับผู้ร้ายที่
เป็นคนจับผู้ร้ายที่เป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาว
ครับ
หน้านี่ครับมนุษย์ต่างดาวมนุษย์ต่างดาว
อ่ะไม่ใช่คนที่อยู่บนโลกนะมนุษย์ต่างดาว
หมายถึงอ่ะตอนนี้ตอนนี้พี่อาร์ตี้น้อง
เรียมแล้วก็ทุกๆคนเป็นเป็นคนใช่ไหมครับ
อยู่บนโลกอะนี่โลกของเรานะแต่มนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวมนุษย์ต่างดาวจะอยู่ที่ดาวดวงอื่นไม่
ได้อยู่บนโลกแต่งหน้าเป็นดาวดวงอื่นเรียก
มนุษย์ต่างดาว
หน้าไปก็มีมนุษย์ต่างดาวมนุษย์ต่างดาวที่
มาอยู่บนโลกม้าอยู่บนโลกมาอยู่บนโลก
ชายไม่เห็น
มีต่างดาว 5 เวลาที่มนุษย์ต่างดาวมาอยู่
บนโลกมนุษย์ต่างดาวก็รอมตัวล้อมตัวให้
เหมือนกับคน
หาใช่ครับเราก็จะไม่รู้ว่าใครเป็นมนุษย์
ต่างดาว
อ่า
ชายเตรียมรู้ได้ยังไงว่าเพียบปีเป็นคน
ไม่ใช่มนุษย์ต่างไปหาฮ่าๆเรียมก็จะไม่รู้
เพราะเพียงตีก็จะไม่บอกไม่บอกว่าพี่
อาร์ตี้เป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาวไหมอ่ะเป็นถือ
ไม่เห็น
แต่แต่สองคนนี้เมื่อสองคนนี้รู้สองคนนี้
รู้ว่าใครใครเป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาว
หน้าแล้วถ้าเป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาวที่ไม่ดี
เป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาวที่เป็นไม่ดีทำไม่ดีเขา
จะไปจับไปจับชายอ่ะ R หน้าคนนี้ชื่อเจคน
นี้ชื่อเคอะสองคนนี้เจอกับเคก็จะไปจับ
มนุษย์ต่างดาวมานะครับหน้าในเรื่องนี้นะ
ครับ
โอเคอ่านี่ครับอ่ะตัวอย่างตอนนี้มีคนนี้
เป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาวที่ไม่ดีและมนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวที่ไม่ดีนะเขาปลอมตัวมาเป็นคนเนียมดู
รู้ไหมครับว่าคนนี้เป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาวดู
รู้ไม่รู้ไม่รู้ใช่ไหมครับ
ไม่รู้ว่าคนนี้เป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาวแต่ค.
เนี่ยรู้โอเคก็จะมาจับโอเคมาจับเคมาจับ
มนุษย์ต่างดาวก็เลยออกมาออกมาจากที่ครอบ
เขาแอบปลอมตัวเป็นคนอยู่หน้านี้ครับนี่
คือตัวจริงๆของมนุษย์ต่างดาวเขาไม่ใช่คน
หน้าเขาถือหัวขัวที่เป็นคนแต่ไม่ใช่คน
เป็นเอ่อหุ่นยนต์เป็นหุ่นยนต์ที่พูด
เหมือนคนเวลาคนเห็นอ้ะเวลาคนเห็นก็เห็น
แต่หัวก็มีคนมีคนจะห่าแต่จริงๆแล้วข้างใน
ข้างในเขาข้างในที่อยู่ในเสื้อคลุมไม่ใช่
คน
เธอมนุษย์ต่างดาวๆๆแล้วโอเคเจอกับเคก็มา
จับไปนะครับแล้วเวลาที่อ่ามีคนมาเห็นมีคน
ไหมคนตอน 27 กับ kma จับมนุษย์ต่างดาวก็
จะมีคนอื่นๆเพื่อนๆของเขาที่อยู่รอบๆก็จะ
เป็นคนอื่นๆเป็นคนเห็นเพราะคนเห็นเจกับ
และก็จะต้องทำให้คนที่เห็นจำไม่ได้จำไม่
ได้ว่าเห็นมนุษย์ต่างดาว
เราเขาทำยังไงค่ะอ่ะอ่ะเขาใช้ค่ะมีปากกา
หนึ่งเขามีประการหนึ่งที่กดอ่ะใช่ครับ
เป็นปากกาเวลากดแล้วจะมีแสงเอามาตรงนี้
หน้ามีแสงออกมาคนที่เห็นแสงคนที่เห็นแสง
ก็จะหาใช่ครับมีแสงแบบนั้นออกมาฮ่าๆๆกับ
มีแสงสว่างออกมาคนที่เห็นแสงก็จะ
ลืมจำไม่ได้จำเหตุการณ์ที่เกิดขึ้นไม่ได้
นี่เรากับเราคุยอะไรกันเถอะ
เตรียมจำไม่ได้เลยใช่ไหมฮ่าๆ
ลืมไปแล้วเก้งอ่ะโอเคแล้วตอนที่เค้ากดอัน
นี้ตอนนี้เขากดเขาก็ต้องใส่แว่นอ่าอ่าใส่
แว่นทำไมรู้ไหมครับ
ใส่แว่นเขาต้องใส่แว่นด้วยเพราะว่าเขา
ป้องกันป้องกันไม่ให้เขาเห็นไม่ให้เขา
เห็นแสงอันนี้อ้าใช่ครับป้องกันแสง
แสงๆเขาก็จะได้ไม่ลืม
หน้าใช่ครับนี่
โอเคอ่ะแล้วก็หลังจากที่เขาจับมนุษย์ต่าง
ดาววันนี้เรียบร้อยแล้วก็มีมนุษย์ต่างดาว
อีกตัวหนึ่งนะครับมายังโลกของเรานี่นั่ง
จานบินมาจานบินอันนี้คือจานบินนักเรียน
รู้จักจันทร์บินไหม
เห็ดจานดีนี่ก็มีนะคะพี่อาร์ตี้อาจารย์
บินด้วยเหรออันนั้นไม่ใช่ลินไม่ได้ดินให้
อันนี้จานใส่ขนมใส่ข้าวกินได้ลูกเหมือน
มากเลยเหมือนกันเนื้อหาคนไทยก็เลยเรียก
จานแต่บิวได้จานบินง่ายจานบินกลับมาจาก
ต่างดาวในจานบินนี้ก็มีมนุษย์ต่างดาวที่
ไม่ดีมาด้วย
มีมนุษย์ต่างดาวที่ไม่ดีมาด้วยในจานบิน
นี้นะครับอ่าอาอามนุษย์ต่างดาวตัวนี้หน้า
ตาเป็นไงรู้ไหมครับนี่หน้าตามันเป็นแบบ
นี้นะครับมันมาที่โลกของเรามาที่โลกของ
เราเพื่อที่จะมัดตามหาต่อมนุษย์ต่างดาวคน
นึงที่มี
พลังงานที่มันต้องการ
นามิของที่มันต้องการใช่มีพลังงานเยอะๆ
น่ะเก็บซ่อนไหมมันจะมาตาม
นะพอมันมาถึงที่โลกแล้วครับ
เขามาแบบนี้คนเห็นก็ต้องตกใจนะคะๆคนเห็น
กลัว
ก็รู้รู้ไม่อยากให้คนรู้ว่าเขาเป็นมนุษย์
ต่างดาวเขาก็รอมดูตัวรอมตัวได้ครับ
เขาก็ปลอมแต่คราวนี้เขาไม่ได้ใส่ผ้าคลุม
ไม่ได้ใส่ผ้าคลุมไม่ได้ถือหัวหัวอีกแล้ว
หน้าที่นี่เขาไปฆ่าผู้ชายคนนึงไปฆ่าผู้
ชายคนนิดใช่ครับค่าแล้วเขาก็เข้าไปอยู่ใน
ตัวผู้ชายคนนี้
หน้ามนุษย์ต่างดาวก็เข้ามาอยู่ในตัวของ
ผู้ชายคนนี้
อ้าใช่ครับคนนี้ก็ตายไปแล้วแต่ว่ายังเดิน
ได้เพราะว่ามนุษย์ต่างดาวอยู่อยู่ข้างใน
ตัวเขา
โอเคแล้วเขาก็ไปตามหาตามหาพลังงานที่เขา
อยากจะได้เขารู้เขารู้ว่าพลังงานที่เขา
อยากจะได้อยู่ที่ผู้ชายคนนี้อยู่ที่ผู้
ชายคนนี้เขาก็เลยตามติดตามมาแล้วก็ฆ่าผู้
ชายคนนี้
ใช่คนนี้เป็นคนหรือว่ามันต่างดาวเป็น
มนุษย์ต่างดาวเหมือนกันนะผู้ชายคนนี้เป็น
มนุษย์ต่างดาวไม่ใช่ขน
เขาค่าเสร็จเขาก็แย่งเอากล่องที่เก็บพลัง
งานไปนะผู้ชายคนนี้มีกล่องที่เก็บพลังงาน
นี่คือกล่องนิกล้องนิมนุษย์ต่างดาวก็แย่ง
ไปเอาไปนะครับงานเสร็จแล้วก็เอาไปแล้ว
นั้นเขาก็ไปเปิดดูเขาก็เปิดดูดูข้างในว่า
มีมีพลังงานที่เขาต้องการอยู่หรือเปล่ามี
ไหม
เสร็จแล้วเขาเปิดดูเปิดออกมาดูไม่มีไม่มี
พลังงานที่เขาต้องการ
ลบพลังงานนี่หรือไม่มีอ่ะพลังงานพลังงาน
ไม่ได้อยู่ที่นี่เขาต่อไปไปตามหาที่บ้าน
ที่บ้านของผู้ชายคนนี้ไปตามหาที่บ้านของ
ผู้ชายคนนี้ว่าพลังงานที่เขาอยากได้อยู่
ไหนอยู่ไหน
น้า
ขอเข้าไปที่บ้านเขาก็ตามไปเจอครับไปเจอ
รูปนี้ครับมีรูปรูปภาพรูปนี้เขาก็เลยเห็น
ผู้ชายคนนี้กำลังอุ้มอุ้มแมวอยู่อุ้มแมว
อีกช้าใช่แล้วเขาก็เขาเห็นสิ่งที่เขา
กำลังหา
ก็คือพลังงานนั้นอ่ะอยู่ตรงนี้ครับมีนี่
มันคือพลังอันนี้หน้าที่อยู่ที่คอแมวนี่
ห้อยอยู่ที่คอแมวนี่มีครับน้าเขาก็เลยเอา
ไป
อาน้องแมวหรอคะ
แมวเขาก็
แมวไม่ตายไม่เอาไม่ตายเข้าเอาคะอันนี้ไป
นะเอาแต่นี้ไปใช่ครับหือเสร็จแล้วนะครับ
จากนั้น
เจเจกับเคก็ตามมาตามมาตามมาเพื่อที่จะจับ
มนุษย์ต่างดาวคนนี้พอมนุษย์ต่างดาวของนี้
เป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาวที่ไม่ดีฆ่าคนฆ่ามนุษย์
ต่างดาวคนอื่นน่าใช้ครับ
แล้วก็ห้าจับยังไงอ้าแต่ตอนนั้นเธอเจกับ
เคยังไม่รู้ยังไม่รู้ว่ายังไม่รู้ว่า
มนุษย์ต่างดาวคนนี้ตามมาเถอะมาที่โลกนี้
แล้วจะมาเอาพลังงานนี้ยังไม่รู้
น่าได้ครับเขาก็เลยไปตามหาไปตามหาจาก
กากผู้ชายคนที่โดนฆ่าครั้งแรกนะครับ
หน้า
5 นี่ไปตามหาคนที่จะโดนฆ่าไปแล้วเจอกับ
เคก็มาเจอมาเจอคนนี้ที่โดนฆ่าตายนะครับ
เจอก็เลยเปิดดูเปิดดูในในตัวของผู้ชายคน
นี้
หน้าเปิดได้เปิดได้ครับเปิดออกมาเขามี
มนุษย์ต่างดาวอยู่ข้างในหน้านี่ผมของเขา
อยู่ตรงนี้หน้ามีหูอยู่ตรงนี้ได้ครับเขา
ไม่ใช่คนเขาปลอมตัวเขาเป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาว
ปลอมตัวเป็นคนเหมือนกัน
ว้าวน่าใช่ครับก็เลยคุยแล้ว
ด้วยใช่ครับเขายังมีแหละมีมีพลังเหลือ
อยู่อีกนิดหน่อยก็เลยบอกก็เลยบอกว่า
มนุษย์ต่างดาวไม่ดีมาฆ่าเขาแล้วก็จะไปเอา
พลังงานของเขาไป
น่าได้ครับเจ๊กับเค้กก็เลยรู้ก็รู้รู้รู้
นะแล้วก็ตามไปตามไปตามไปเพื่อที่จะเอา
พลังงานคืนมานะครับหน้าแล้วก็ถามไปเจอ
ครับเจก็ตามไปจนเจอเพราะตามมาเจอก็เลยสู้
กันทั้งเจ๊กับแค่ก็สู้กับมนุษย์ต่างดาว
อ้าวแล้วมันต่างดาวไม่ได้เป็นคนแบบนี้
แล้วหรอคะอาตอนที่ก่อนที่เจอกันเป็นคนตอน
ที่เจอกันเป็นคนแต่เจ๊กับเครู้รู้ว่านี่
ไม่ใช่คนจะเจอกับเครู้หน้ารู้ว่าอ่า
มนุษย์ต่างดาวตัวนี้ไม่ใช่คนนั้นแกก็ไป
ตัดจับพอจะจับพอจะเข้าไปจับมนุษย์ต่างดาว
ก็กลายร่างเป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาวจริงๆไม่ปลอม
ตัวแล้วเราก็สู้กัน
หน้าซ้ายครับก็เลยสู้กันเจ๊กับเคก็เลยเอา
ปืนออกมาครับอ๊อฟปืนออกมาเตรียมที่จะก็
เตรียมที่จะยิงมนุษย์ต่างดาวตัวนี้แต่
หรือทางดาวตัวนี้ก็สู้ด้วยหรือต่างเราก็
ใช้ลิ้นมีลิ้นมีลิ้นยาวมากลิ้นที่ยาวออก
มาจายันแลบลิ้นออกมาออกมาทำอะไรคะพี่ออก
มาแล้วก็จับปืน
จับปืนจับปืนของของเจกับ K2 ก็บอกแล้วก็
กินปืนเข้าไป
คือมนุษย์ต่างดาวไม่มีมือ
อ่ะมีมือแต่ว่าแต่ว่ามือสั้นแต่ลิ้มยาว
ลิงค์ยาว
ได้ครับลิ้นยาวก็เลยมาจับปืนเอาลิ้นมา
ปุ๊บแล้วก็จับปืนอะลิ้นมาจับปืนแล้วก็กิน
ปืนเข้าไปเจอกับเคก็เอามาให้มีปืนให้มี
ปืนแล้วเธอยิงมนุษย์ด่างดาวก็ยังไงยิงไม่
ได้เจอช่างแล้ว
แบบนี้ล่ะค่ะอ่าอ่าจะสู้แบบนี้สู้ไม่ได้
เพราะมนุษย์ต่างดาวตัวใหญ่กว่ามากใหญ่
กว่าหน้ามนุษย์ต่างดาวจะตัวใหญ่กว่าใหญ่
กว่าเจอกับเคมากอ่านแล้วโอเคก็เลยคิดเค้ก
เลยคิดคลิปอาจจะทำยังไงถึงจะเอาปืนคืนมา
เพราะปืนอยู่ในท้องอยู่ในท้องของมนุษย์
ต่างดาวแล้วตอนนี้นะฮะโอเคก็เลยเห้ยโอเค
ก็เลยบอกให้มนุษย์ต่างดาวกินกินเคเข้าไป
วัวปลาใช่ครับมันขึ้นทางดาวอ่ะโอเคก็เลย
พูดพูดไม่ดีพูดไม่ดีกับมนุษย์ต่างดาว
มนุษย์ต่างดาวก็โกรธโกรธโกรธก็เลยกินเค
เข้าไป
กินเคก็ไปด้วยเคก็เลยเข้าไปอยู่ในท้องๆ
ของมนุษย์ต่างดาว
หน้าก็คิดครั้งก็ไม่ได้คิดนะว่าเขาโดนกิน
แล้วก็ตายหรือไม่ใช่กลัวเคไม่ตายเพราะเค
เข้าไปอยู่ในท้องของมนุษย์ต่างดาวโอเคก็
ไปเอาปืนในท้องแล้วก็ยิ่งไม่รู้จะทางดาว
ออกมาจากในท้อง
อ้าๆแล้วมนุษย์ต่างดาวก็เลยตาย
ตายนุชทางเราก็เลยตายหาโอเคเคโดนกินไม่
ตายให้ครับต่างดาวตายอ้ะถูกยิงจากในท้อง
ระเบิดออกมาวิวทหารก็เลยตายเจอ
ก็จบเรื่องนี้ครับนี่คือภาคที่ 1 ท่าที่ 1
นะเนี่ยภาคที่ 1 เรื่องของมนุษย์ต่างดาว
ที่มาทำโอยพลังงานแล้วเจอกับเค้กตามไปจับ
แล้วก็ฆ่ามนุษย์ต่างดาวได้ก็อ่าโอเคมี
นักเรียนคนไหนที่เคยดูเคยดูหนังเรื่อง mib
ไหมอ่าเคยดูไหมครับเฮียที่อาจจะเล่าอาจจะ
เล่าได้นิดหน่อยเล่าไม่ครบทั้งเรื่องถ้า
นักเรียนอยากรู้อ่ะใช่ครับอยากรู้ก็ไปดู
เรื่องครั้งหมดทั้งหมดครั้งเรื่องได้ไหม
ครับโอเคอ่าแล้ววันนี้นะครับหมดเวลาแล้ว
ครับนักเรียนใช้ครับหมดเวลาแล้วนะครับ
เดี๋ยวพี่กับน้องเรียนต้องลาไปก่อนครับ
ถ้าใครดูแล้วชอบพี่นิกกด like กด
Subscribe ให้ด้วยนะครับแล้วก็กลับมาเจอ
กันใหม่ข่าวนะครับ
ๆค่ะเราจะเล่าเรื่องอะไรต้องรอดูค่าใช่หา
ทรายครับผมลาไปก่อนครับสวัสดีครับบ๊ายบาย
ๆ
ทีนี้ถ้านักเรียนไม่ว่างอ่ะ